Jones co-star Lorenz Tate caught in a
rainy reunion you better stop
it's in the rain LT yes I love you back
baby always and forever
my favorite favorite Forever Love Jones
co-star this is my guy the former
castmates shared this sweet clip after
running into each other and yeah things
do happen in the rain longtime fans of
Love Jones will remember the closing
scene of the film where Darius confesses
his love for Nina in the pouring rain
let me tell you something
this here
right now at this very moment is all
that matters to me
I love you she wants to say that I'm her
favorite leading man of all time I was
just saying for her the on-screen love
interests stole viewers hearts in the
cult classic and E.T was on sale with
Nia back in 1996 when she shared her
true feelings about that epic moment we
shoot the scene in the rain and it's
pouring down rain and it's like supposed
to be this passionate thing and Lorenz
and I are wrapped in plastic to stay dry
so it's pretty funny it's like you'd
never expect it but as you're walking
you hear
because the plastic is under our clothes
so it's pretty cute at the time the
store also admitted how she personally
related to her character Nina Mosley
she's going through a bit of a
tormenting time in in the love
Department she just realizes that that
relationship is not right for her and
it's very painful and it's something
that all women go through at some point
in time in their life and she meets
Darius who's played by Lorenz Tate and
love at first sight basically I've been
in situa in a situation in my own life
where I was going through a breakup and
I started seeing someone else and you
kind of go back to make sure is it
really over and then you get there and
you're like oh yeah this is really over
and you move on with your life and it's
hard it's painful at times but it's all
about a learning experience the rom-com
just celebrated its 26th anniversary and
still holds up as fans revisit it time
and time again honestly to see so many
generations love that movie and the fact
the movie is timeless we put it in a
Time castle and it feels good so I mean
there's been so many great memories on
on on that um that production and us
working for me more than anything it's
just what people have taken away from it
they say that it changed their lives
that means a lot to me meaning their
relationship's gotten better you know
and a lot of the tough guys you know
have said listen man I know I keep an OG
I'm A Gangster but when they watch Love
Jones it really you know brings that
that heart out of them and it's kind of
nice to see that